so if this becomes a hit then you know
work you know they'll be great and if it
doesn't we're still gonna be great but
what we won't we won't see each other
yeah I've known is that you you see you
see people you've done shows with I do
some of my best friends are people that
I that I've done shows with Wow Oh Sara
Rue du u n-- who's there yeah I worked
with her on that show Eastwick and she
lives down the street she moved on my
street we don't see each other as much
as you should if you she's my friend
Wow yeah Rebecca Romain Wow very very
good friend mystique misty was she misty
yeah yeah she was misty original
mystique yeah you met her on lipstick on
also Eastwick used to come in yeah
because when I did animal practice you
know I I worked I love Tyler Labine I
love Justin Kirk so and then you don't
speak to them anymore
typical like that's you pretend you you
know you during when you're shooting you
text each other through the night you
you plan dinners yeah you you you
sometimes you plan getaways and you
don't sharing something like a common
thing you know why as soon as it ended I
haven't seen any of them not one of them
I've seen Betsy sodaro because she works
at UCB I'll Drive down Frankland and
I'll see her waddle down the street and
I'll honk my horn
no Betsy that's it but you talk to all
your MADtv friends though
you guys are super not really I mean
Jordan help me get that job so you've
helped to me but that that maybe it's me
it is you it's not you good wife bad way
it's not you tell me why he's really bad
at checking in with friends just to say
like hey how you how you doing or even
replying to text messages it's it has to
be work-related or he's not gonna reply
I am even worse than you with text
messages anyone that knows me will tell
you that like I'm shockingly bad with
communication so maybe we'll actually
end up staying friends because we won't
have expectations of one another when
you show gets canceled do you know me
and we'll just be like it'll be cool and
no one's gonna get their feelings hurt
and we'll have a meaningful text
connection once every year but we could
call each other friends no sounds like a
Korean thing I just like I like to like
be in the moment man yeah yeah I'm much
like that too and it's just kind of sad
to think about but you know what the end
of the day it's like I know it's me and
now now I'm getting into issues of my
character defects and about things I
need to improve about myself but will
they change probably not I'm stuck in my
ways and and I hate that about myself
there's a lot of character defects that
I have about myself that I [ __ ] hate I
come on yeah come on yeah I want to go
down this rabbit hole ABCs no I want to
go down this road
you're doing a TV star self-deprecation
thing oh my character defects they come
on Bobby I love gold no one like I just
wanna know one character yeah and then
we can move on I like to know things I
have a I have an OCD obsession as she
knows like for instance American Idol oh
my god you guys I know so doing my head
in I can yeah great I watched him the
same episodes American Idol 80 or 90
times so like the last Hollywood one
I've seen it
you asked me framed my frame what's in
the frame of each shot he knows the
extras
he knows people in the audience what do
each audience members reaction is each
frame yeah yeah I know everything about
it all I watch it 24/7 farming in quirky
it's like nah I have to tell you
psychotic it's weird weird yeah but
what's what how does it affect you know
the riot right I'm not gonna like you
know you don't create a human
trafficking business which I would love
to do one day but I don't have the means
lazy coddle I don't have a dungeon but I
did hear you like we are dressing room
walls are super thin yeah and I did hear
you listen to a lot of performances like
super endearing like I was just imagine
you in there like watching your you know
performances but III go to star do
Valley the reason why I love it so much
the video game is because there's four
seasons right and you plant the same
crops you in then when they grow you
pick it up and you do it season by
season I do it 24/7 I just like
repetitive things too as well okay and
it's really just weird and I just don't
know why I'm like that I'll tell you
something weird that I
there we go this is all I wanted to get
this out of you it's stupid it's
probably less weird than yours but much
more normal
if it's not weird it's gonna really bum
me out so make it weird if I have to go
to the bathroom once a day like every
day that's weird I every time I cross a
crosswalk I can't I have to count thee
you know the white man yeah and I ask
myself a question like am I going to get
this job or does this person like me or
something and then I and it's yes no yes
no yes no it is our answer right and
like I can't and if I forget to do what
I have to go back and do it you have a
little bit of an OCD - yeah yeah or like
numbers I'll look at this time and I'll
add up all the numbers and I'll reduce
it down to one number and if it's an odd
number it's a good day and it's weird
right like it's kind of tell her what
you do babe with the [ __ ] wrinkles on
the feet yeah I just sprinkle my feet
with water or else I can't go on with my
day
like I will select module like
shriveling oh look through the crack of
like the door she's not going to leave
the door and I can see her like taking a
[ __ ] right right but while I'm doing it
I use like sprinkling water from the
sink no you know we have the foul ball
so we have to wash when we you know go
to the bathroom and so I bring I always
have a tub of water next to me and I I
dip both of my hands in and I just let
it rain on my feet I have to do that
every way that sounds lovely where do we
get these weird things though like I
can't it's a weird you know work and in
if you I have that too if I don't touch
this doorknob with both hands three
times that someone's gonna leave my head
I think someone's gonna die or something
Bad's gonna happen so what is that
technically OCD or is it like I think
that's just a like probably some I don't
think it's OCD as a
like an actual disorder right but it has
some traits of it right if it doesn't
you know get in the way of your daily
life I don't think it's a problem but if
it's driving you crazy yeah what if it's
routine ancient superstition I think my
mother super-super she was my mom was
very superstitious so I do do weird
things like that I'm like I cannot sleep
a full night unless I do like a backflip
and then you know like my mom like when
you when you get your period you have to
take like three steps forward and the
she has to throw flour and everything
you know yeah like weird [ __ ] like and
I'm like why she was all you're a woman
now you're gonna have a good way I have
a weird one why never shared oh gosh and
we might have to cut this out it's so
weird okay but I don't know if you know
this but I have a bad left foot this is
actually really good information for you
to have since you'll be working with him
if you have to see never touch never
just just you know go touch when you're
clear from the foot from the feet she's
freaking out it's Rogers about it but
it's rotting away ha ha ha
it's a phone what do you mean that what
do you mean what you mean it's a fungus
lady like you like like like the bottoms
are disappearing yeah
[Music]
what I can fix this but I refuse her in
spine but I sometimes I do this I
shouldn't now already now it's weird
you already said the bottom no no I do
something different oh it's new yeah
something I've never shared before
nervous okay so sometimes sometimes I'll
strip some skin from it uh-huh
right it'll be like a certain length and
width right okay and then I had to strip
two more okay the same exact size
right I'm picturing you do this in such
a specific way yeah and if I don't do
your counting in your head yeah so at
first it was just that right at first it
was just that right but remember we had
the clock where we would look in the
ceiling so I had this projection clock
and it would hit the ceiling so in the
darkness you can see what time it is
cool so when I wake up in the morning
and I open my eyes I have to turn my
head I'm lazy okay but so when she's
sleeping I'll strip like one strip off
of my leg foot I mean but I look at the
clock and I have to do it before it hits
a certain time so I put an extra like
challenge on element element of danger
to it so it's was that weird yes
[Laughter]
[Music]